You've probably heard of a pride of lions, a pod
of whales, a swarm of bees - maybe even
a murderof crows. But how about a
parliament of owls? A shrewdness
of Apes? An obstinacy of Buffalo?
A bask of crocodiles or a convocation
of eagles? Wait why is this happening?
Why should every species get
their own collective noun?
No one could ever memorize all these.
The practice, called terms of venery,
dates back to the aristocratic hunting
traditions of the late Middle Ages.
It was aninsider's jargon to tell
who the real hunters were. Did you
hear Roderick of Hertfordshire say pack offoxes?
Everyone knows it's called a skulk! Kind of like
how modern sports fans have
their own slang, like...
Actually I don't know any sports slang. Overthe
years it developed into a playful
linguistic custom. A way to sound
clever at social gatherings. Which
is basically what it still is today.
It has no other real purpose. So the next
time you're at a party and someone says,
"actually it's a drift of pigs" - feel free to
drift away.